he's part of the NFL Network draft
coverage this week as Fox's simulcasting
the NFL Network draft coverage starting
on Thursday night he's Joel cloud how
you doing Joel good man how are you
today well I'm great I'm doing great you
ready for the draft ready again there
could not be I could not be more ready I
feel like a college freshman for my
first final and I have over prepared
there's no question about it hmm
so are you over packing as well are you
an over-packer when you go on on road
trips Joel you know what like if I'm
going to a game or something like I've
done it so many times I know exactly
what I basically packed like the exact
same things every single week but now
this is all new to me and so yeah sure
I'm sure that I will you know know
probably gonna be over and I'll have a
spare you gotta have a spare suit right
well you need yeah I mean just in case
one doesn't arrive or or you just need
to go to or you know hey we want you on
Saturday and we could swing that you
never know but I'm just wondering you
can't wear the same thing around Gus
week to week though go Joel right he'll
he'll call you out on that
oh he'll for sure call me out so that
that's been a challenge with the week
certainly for someone not wardrobe
inclined but you know I do I do what I
can
he actually you know rich what he calls
me out more so okay for is every single
week he walks up and the first thing he
says to me whatever city whatever time
of data we we see each other
he says him your wallet and I'm like oh
and I handed my wallet he's like he's
like son you gotta start carrying more
cash so I carry more cash where should
do come on if you're around Gus you got
to bring your a-game and we're excited
we're excited at the NFL Network to be
partnering with Fox and with you and
Troy Aikman is gonna be part of night
one as well this is going to be great
you're the you're the Cleveland Browns
you take who Joel I would take Donald
you know I having played the position
and and know what it's like to go
through the recruiting process or lack
thereof you know in some cases and and
what it's like to be in college and and
to have a team around you that is really
good one year and maybe not not that's
the next there's one thing that I'm
really concerned about for Josh Allen
and and that's the fact that he never
really dominated in any particular facet
or any one game really throughout his
career and you look at all these other
guys they put their team on their back
at some point and Sam Donald certainly
did that I was still impressed with him
everyone talks about the the lack of
supporting cast for Allen but but really
I think you got to talk about that with
Sam Donald because of what he did
haven't didn't have this last year at
USC I was fortunate enough to do the
Stanford game and the Texas game for for
Donald and he was brilliant and and I
never got that sense from Allen he's
incredibly gifted he's a great kid smart
you'd love him on your football team but
but Darnell's the guy for me he played
so big in big moments and I think that's
what really pays dividends at the next
level and you also were there for the if
I'm not mistaken for the Josh Rosen LED
comeback on Texas A&M Joel correct right
that was on your air with Gus and you
guys were also all in that game too but
you have Rosen drop into seven with the
bills coming up to go get him and get
him out of the green room why do you
think so many mock drafts have him
dropping out of the top five top ten
Joel I mean where do you stand on this
kid haven't been around him I'm sure as
much as you have yeah listen
he is let's take this in three parts you
know you know on the field and then and
then the red flags on the field it may
be awful you got it first on the field
as a player rich there's not a better
pure quarterback in the draft than Rosa
he's beautiful
like his efficiency of movement and and
the efficiency of the arm emotion the
ability to make every single throw you
know he not only can drive the football
outside of the numbers but he can layer
it inside the numbers he's got a great
mind he can change arm angles he does
everything really well now on the field
the red flags is the durability you
cannot win games from the sidelines as a
quarterback and so the fact that he has
dealt with shoulder issues and
concussion issues which is a major red
flag that's going to scare some teams
and then you get to the you know
quote-unquote attitude or personality
which let's face it is not going to be a
fit everywhere you know Josh is a
supremely confident kid not only in his
ability but also in his intellect and at
times that can rub some of these
hardcore football people the wrong way I
think that the article he did with the
ESPN The Magazine is going to hurt him
because it was laced with contradictions
he talked about the fact that one of the
biggest things that he regretted from
college was the hoopla about the Trump
issue with the Hat on the golf course
and he said as big as regret was using
the f-word
which I understand he said hey I'm a
role model I regret using the f-word and
then all of a sudden you were three
other times in the interview and I was
like oui which one is it and again these
these guys are looking for reasons not
to draft you and unfortunately for Rosen
there's too many of those flags first
with durability and then
personality-wise that I could see him up
the top for being the one that slipped a
little bit so what was his relationship
with Jim Mora like and the rest of the
team inside that locker room Joel listen
his teammates loved Josh and this is
such a nasty question because it's such
a different love than than the love that
the Oklahoma players had for Baker
Mayfield you know Baker was I mean he
was everybody's bro on the team you know
they they loved him like a brother and
and Rosen was a little different than
that they loved him because he was their
quarterback and he played hard and he
was tough but you get the sense that you
know he he floated a little bit as it
relates to the strong relationships and
the relational aspect from from you know
segments of the team to segment the team
and certainly from the high school era
into the college there was an interview
he did last year before the season I
really rubbed me the wrong way and
probed a lot of his teammates the wrong
way behind closed doors he said hey I
chose UCLA to mess with people and he
said that publicly in an interview and
I'm not here to disparage Josh Rosen
like I said he's a beaut
player but if you're his teammate at
UCLA and you're basically saying like he
came here because he thought it was a
joke and it was funny and he was gonna
mess with people and he should have gone
to USC or Notre Dame or some one of
these other places that's not
necessarily the way to really you know
get yourself in the good graces with
your teammates his relationship with
Maura I felt like was good but I felt
like Jim always had to work on it and he
was constantly maybe on on eggshells a
little bit with us but end of the day
that gives a beautiful football player
and like I said and and there are some
markets and some teams that are going to
be able to handle that just fine rich
and and candidly
I think the Giants are one of those I
think New York is the perfect market for
him I have Alan going to the Giants but
I think rosin probably should go to the
Giants because one thing we know about
the New York Giants you can be your own
man and your own person and your own
brand and still be a part of that
franchise and I think we've seen that in
several different cases a couple more
minutes here left with Joel clad of Fox
Sports part of the NFL draft coverage
this week in the Fox broadcast of the
NFL Network draft coverage and the
thrilled to be part and parcel of
everybody on that front so night - Joel
assuming you know we're gonna get a
whole bunch of quarterbacks named on
night two as well that have an
opportunity like Jimmy Garoppolo Derek
Carr Andy Dalton Colin Kaepernick just
to name a few off the top of my head to
have noteworthy professional football
playing careers most of which are still
going on right now who do you like
that's a night to guy for the NFL Joe
I'm a big fan of Lamar Jackson I think
he's gonna be a night to guide don't
think he's going to get into the the
first round I'm a really big fan of Kyle
lettuce from Richmond love his game and
and the way that he plays it very much
an NFL ready style game reminds me a lot
of you can call it that this might be
disparaging but maybe a poor man's Jimmy
Garoppolo but back to Lamar Jackson rich
this is the type of guy that's so
dynamic on the football field but I
think he helps your franchise day one
while he's still developing the
requisite skills to be
and every down quarterback in the
starting quarterback very similar to
Kordell Stewart back with the Pittsburgh
Steelers you know back in in the mid 90s
so I think Lamar with the right creative
coach could make a big splash in the
National Football League and I think
he'll be one of the most impactful
players taken on night two from that
position and then I do also want to say
there's gonna be a lot of running backs
on Friday night rich selected that are
gonna be huge contributors next year and
we saw that last year obviously with you
know those running backs like Kamara get
and taking them the second night but I
think there's going to be several of
those guys maybe four shot penny from
San Diego State yeah drop some more of
those names who else I like you know I
think Ronald Jones might slip into the
second round I think we're gonna have
both Georgia backs Nick job as well as
Tony Michelle we've got several I think
wide receivers that are gonna slip into
the second round maybe DJ more from
Maryland slips into the second round I
think he can help somebody in the slot
potentially Cristian Kirk slits into the
second round Courtland Sutton Hoo the
Cowboys have been seemingly targeting
maybe he slipped to Siletz in the second
round so those are the skilled position
players that I'm looking at that I feel
like have a chance to be really
impactful guys on that night - all right
Joel a look as you know a huge fan of
yours
fan of your work the fact that you're
part of a draft coverage this week is
huge I look forward to getting a chance
to work with you and just know this when
you you're part of the draft coverage
that we've been doing on the NFL Network
for so long
mike Mayock only speaks to those he
speaks to don't speak to him first okay
Joel right right ah see that's the
benchmark what if I do that on the air
Friday night with nobody knowing that
we've had this conversation but you know
what if I do that I'll own you that way
what if I throw to you that way what's
in your wallet well then let me give you
I'm looking right now okay I'm gonna hit
the when I hit the old ATM and then
we'll do that
of course then if I asked you that
question that I'll get I'll get emails
from the NFL like we do not
have a sponsorship with Capital One do
not ask him a question right that is not
the official card of the NFL Joey you
take care of man I look forward to
seeing you in the Metroplex and down
yeah wait all right right thanks much
you got it Joel class the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience